okay welcome to this video I had to just
recording a little bit i think the
latest two or three videos might have
been a little bit off in terms of screen
estate who is that Mario only pulled oh
let's go on okay so let's go is kind of
a not a very stealthy handle then but I
wasn't aware of a play off that name so
we got a Coonskin with me just this I
also play the exchange variation but
let's see what we get him
yeah the semi sloth will be three yeah
Quincy to some am a main main entire
Moran variation ok this one he's six mmm
okay maybe he's out for beef I've never
seen that move that's uncommon usually
you try to do this in a situation where
widest somehow forced to play Bishop t2
in this kind of situation it's supposed
to be just good for wide
that's a strange opening I'm just a
pretty bad version of it over Dutch
Dutch Stonewall okay well he can go back
to the sexy on you may be some kind of
like a move down or so on a on a normal
position maybe ok so I'm we rooting the
night it wants to go to f4 here let's
see I can go maybe I always like to get
in Bishop e3 if I have the chance in
this kind of position think about a four
yeah a form a five Bush of a three and
queen e seven I think of I'm well
positioned to to play this as if I've
now hence me the d4 square it's still
probably what he should do no okay
page six I don't really think that this
can be he can degrade
don't think i'm getting checkmated to
you quickly would be be somewhat weird
okay so do i take on c6 or B 6v6 not
sure I think I probably should take so
what does he going for G 40 f 1
yeah let's see yeah I think this is a an
opportunity that I should take just
attacking you five and taking on your
five is pretty awful so f three now and
then F for something let's push the
night out
I didn't see that idea at all oh come on
really yeah is probably probably working
ah how annoying is that the position was
just rity chicly winning winning flat
out winning with this nonsensical piece
I just didn't look at Queen h5 at all
okay let's hope it it's still kind of
interesting and not flat out losing so
if I take you for even it's even the
trap of this piece I can go night at
four first maybe do that then take you
four maybe still is maybe it's still
kind of okay maybe
I can understand any more from this guy
no not a single one why not FTX I'm a
bishop has no square and anyway he wants
to take with the pawn and go for Luke
age to yes probably this is the this is
the idea
tween age for 3g tool
this is probably had a rupee tool and
the next move let's say then he has
screen edge form they cannot really
defend against win h1
kanji tool is always rook h2 it is very
tricky to defend this Chianti is six
unfortunately
and fatigue it I don't know Teague's
guess this one for look for possible
look on the and the D file this was the
idea didn't didn't get that
but I think write a three and if i cant
can sec the exchange that might be might
be playable what I don't have don't get
I don't see any move here not a single
move from in check well I should be okay
again right time morning america money i
would really want to trade Quincy so
let's get out of this this bloody pin
I Scott got the rook check as well
unbelievably it's still tricky I can
take you can take defending on f2 why is
he not losing on time what is last for
its I'm crying and I'm such a [ __ ]
sometimes here this position is
strategically winning for wider almost
yeah he's got no attack really no attack
if I I'm not blundering this every Queen
h5 but exactly what am I playing besides
if three
you know the one you know what the the
sick thing is I can just play 93 and I
didn't see that move I really thought I
cannot defend age too wow this is still
just good for wide and weird instead I
went each floor this is probably
suicidal funny engines as equal but not
with this I'm still equal here htx 23
right what is the engine giving here
gives black a slight advantage and this
kind of evaluation is so irritating
engine wants me to play look everyone
now that position felt very scary I felt
very scary okay and this was winning now
antiques Teague's I'm a 74 Luke g7 and
then g2 he must have had a win damn it
it is just it was just so dangerous I
hit 96 was winning directly I was just
an totally off game but played a
terribly check yeah this is losing and
this is winning is winning for black
check yeah yeah I'm winning but I still
managed to put me into problems okay
Rupert e7 now would have decided again
route is 7 yeah I couldn't really make
it work in term
I don't know what that is honey engine
gives 000 it probably see some kind of
Perpetual yeah ah what it has a bad game
I think I need a break thanks for
watching